[Arabic recitation]
in the 68th chapter of the Quran
and we have reached the second and third
verses in this chapter.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is speaking
to the prophet Sam
he says to him.
So in these three verses
verse number two three and four he says
subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to again speaking addressing
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
He says,
"You
by the grace of your Lord are not in any
way insane."
And we understand this additional
emphasis. He's not just saying you are
not insane. He is saying you are not the
least bit insane.
form.
[Silence]
He says,
"You are not by the grace of your Lord
the least bit insane." And this of
course is a reputation of the
accusations and rumors of his
antagonists.
Our prophet sallallah.aii wasallam's
antagonist
were saying to him and saying about him
that he is crazy.
And comes from the root word or the past
tense verb ja.
And ja
usually means insanity and oftent times
insanity with a kind of almost spiritual
bent to it. So an insanity that comes by
way of
devils or the interference of
or jin in a person possessing them
right and so here Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is saying you are not in the
least bit insane you are not in the
least bit possessed
And of course this is meant to praise
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. And
anytime praise is intended with a
negating statement
we affirm it's what?
We affirm it's what we affirmation.
[Arabic recitation]
Otherwise it's not praise.
Pure negation doesn't praise anything.
If I say so and so is not crazy, that
doesn't mean he's intelligent. It's not
praise. It just means he's not that. It
takes a person from the negative back to
zero. It takes a person back to
and so if I say a person is not a liar
doesn't necessarily mean that they speak
the truth all the time. Just means that
they don't do that. So and so is not a
thief doesn't mean that they're
necessarily trustworthy.
And so the only way negation, the only
way a negating sentence
is considered praise is if we understand
its exact opposite. You are not in the
least bit insane by the grace of your
Lord. Rather, by the grace of your Lord,
you are fully sane and conscious. And
the furthest thing from possession,
the Quran is described as having no
doubt in it.
Well, that doesn't necessarily mean that
it contains certainty. Just means it
doesn't have anything doubtful. No, we
always affirm the opposite. So this
verse means that the Quran has no doubt
in it and has every
and has every element of certainty in
all of its verses. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says that but just
because what people are saying about me
isn't true doesn't mean that it doesn't
make me upset that they're saying it.
Right? Just because I know that
something is not true
doesn't mean that it doesn't hurt
for these things to be said. And so
what can I do about that? Can I change
the world? Can I micromanage every
single human being and make sure
that they never say
anything insulting to me? This is
impossible. The only thing a person can
do is what?
What's the only thing you can do with
that?
Be patient. And what makes a person
patient?
Keeping a person
focused on the reward
for that patience. And so what does
Allah say in the following verse?
[Arabic recitation]
le in the least bit by the grace of your
Lord the least bit insane or possessed.
Rather, you are of the highest level of
or the furthest thing from that and
indeed for you is a great reward." And
so two things for a person to be able to
be patient with a rumor, something
that's not true, right? Or something
that is said about them that is
negative. Number one, that they make
sure that that is not true about them.
And number two, that they remember the
reward of Allah for patience.
And then if a person has this recipe,
they can outweigh anyone. They can have
the patience of the most patient as long
as they keep in their mind's eye their
eye on the goal which is the reward of
Allah subhanahaala.
This statement of Allah
[Silence]
And so this is all tying back to the
original oath that took at the beginning
of the chapter noon. I swear by the pen
and all that they write.
I swear by the pen and all that they
write. Indeed, you are not in the least
bit insane. And I further swear by the
pen and all that they write. That for
you is an incredible
and unending reward.
So here Allah mentions two aspects of
this reward.
The first thing is that it is reward for
his deeds and he affirms that with this
that certainly indeed without a without
a doubt without the least bit doubt
that for you is a great reward. And
second, this reward is described as
it is a reward that has no end.
It is a reward that has no end.
forch.
[Silence]
He says, "And indeed for you there is a
a reward that is unending."
Then he affirms,
he affirms the opposite and he praises
him for his patience. And he says,
[Silence]
forch.
He says, "And indeed, this is all going
back to that original that original oath
that Allah took." And that is and I
swear
by the I swear by the pen and all that
they write. This goes back to each one
of these sentences. So we understand
this to be
I swear by the pen and all that they
write that you by the grace of your Lord
are not the le least bit insane.
And I further swear by the pen and all
that they write that for you is an
unending and grand reward.
And I further swear by the pen and all
that they write that you are upon
a very great and high level of
character. Here we have the word huluk.
Hulk
is
taken from the same root word as alkal
is something that is created, right?
It's something that's created. Well, the
word for character and etiquette is
taken from that same root word. Why?
Because it's an extension of a person's
physical being.
Just is for your physical traits,
al is for your the traits of your
character, the traits of your spirit.
These are the physical traits of your
spirit or the literal traits of your
spirit. This is referred to as what?
And your physical traits in Arabic are
referred to as what?
So
physical body
the traits of a person's soul who they
really are those traits are referred to
as and
but there's another point here and that
is that in the Arabic language is only
used to describe what a person has
earned by his own free will.
What does that mean?
That means that if a person is patient,
are they choosing by their free will to
be patient?
Yes.
This we can describe as being what?
Asuk.
Likewise, if a person is a coward, are
they choosing to be a coward? Yes. So we
refer to this as
but if a person cannot speak is
physically mute and is unable to speak
can we say this person is a few words
this is part of his
he has very good etiquette he doesn't
talk very much no we don't call this we
call this
right and it's also referred to as.
[Silence]
So here when Allah is praising the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he's
saying
he's saying you
have
very good etiquette but not only is it
that he has good etiquette but he has
disciplined himself to have this
etiquette. It's not just something Allah
just gave him that
he just had he was created that way.
He couldn't have been any other way. No,
that is why he's being rewarded for it.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala rewards the
person for that which he
disciplines himself to earn.
[Silence]
Sai wasallam and so he has great
character. Now usually when we say the
word character
what
is the most usual thing that pops into
your mind when we say character say face
he has good character what did you think
of right now tell me
yeah tell me what's the first thing
that comes into your mind
Adam What's the first thing that comes
into your mind when I say good
character?
You just said exactly what he said. I'm
asking you to say something else. What
is the first thing that comes into your
mind when I say the prophet had good
character?
[Arabic recitation]
Truthful. What else?
Trustworthiness.
An incredible aspect of character that
usually
is not regarded as character. What else?
Honesty.
[Arabic recitation]
What about jealousy?
No.
[Arabic recitation]
dead in the water. Are you insecure?
You're jealous.
How could you be jealous?
[Arabic recitation]
Is that what our prophet teaches us?
bad jealousy?
[Arabic recitation]
Do we throw the baby out with the
proverbial bathwater?
Huh?
What else
[Arabic recitation]
part of good character? Can anger be
part of good character?
I'm asking
what about if the boundaries of Allah
are crossed but you're c cool as a
cucumber.
No problem.
smiling away,
breezing out. What do you think?
Huh?
You know, cursed, cursed be the ones who
have convinced us
that and confused us
that nice and good are the same thing.
Cursed are those who have confused us
and swindled us into believing that nice
and good are the same thing cuz they're
not.
Good isn't always nice
and bad is most often nice.
When we look at
she was asked this exact question.
What was the prophet's character?
The greatest description for that, every
one of us knows this. What is it?
That the Quran was his character. We
read the Quran. What do we find? Do we
find anger for the sake of Allah in the
Quran?
Does Allah become angry?
Allah never becomes angry.
[Silence]
Okay. So
we have confused
a smile for good character.
That is a part of good character. But it
is only a part of good character when
what's behind the smile is trustworthy.
What about when you wear a smile but in
the hand is a velvet glove with a very
sharp knife. Is that good character?
Huh? Or do we or is that most akin to a
reptile?
See, and this is the issue. We cannot
sum good character into one or two
traits.
That's why said
Quran Quran was his character. You look
at MS he bea he becomes so angry for the
sake of Allah that he throws the tablets
out of his hands
and he grabs his brother by the beard.
What did I tell you to do? They're
worshiping idols and I've only been gone
for a little over a month.
We see
that Yuisam
tells
the the guy that got out of prison, he
said, "Look, as I told you, you're going
to be very close to the king. So when
you get there, just ask one thing.
Please tell the king that I'm here and
just to look into my case. That's it.
Nothing else. He didn't say intercede.
He didn't say anything. He just said
when you get there, you get all the way
to the top. All right? Don't forget
about us down here. Just please tell the
king that I'm here.
Just tell him to look into my case.
Don't even argue for me. Just tell him,
"Hey, there's this guy, his name is
Ysef. He's in jail. Maybe look into the
case. I'll do the rest. The guy left and
left Ysef's remembrance there with him
in the jail.
As a matter of fact, he didn't just
forget Ysef. He forgot him so thoroughly
that an almost a decade went by. got
didn't even didn't even go through his
mind again in over seven years. And then
the king comes out one day and he says,
"I saw a dream. This dream here
tell me about this dream." You know,
explain it. And
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
now everyone in the court all the
courtiers and the servants and
everyone's thinking how can he
ingratiate himself to the king how can I
be the guy that interprets the dream or
that I can be instrumental in him you
know interpreting this dream. He's just
the guy that makes the wine, right?
Allah said,
"This guy sat down and racked his brain
for a time
until he finally remembered Ysef."
That's how thoroughly he forgot about
him.
He remembered him only when he needed
him. Correct.
Does that sting or not? It stings,
right? Especially if anybody here has
ever experienced jail or prison. May
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala protect
everyone. The kind of brotherhood that
takes place in prison is very very
unique.
You bond,
right? Because the smallest things
become important there and you have no
one else.
And so
he ran back to Ysef. Didn't even say
sorry. didn't even apolog
[Silence]
now you need me. Oh, now you remembered
me. What did he say?
I'm dealing with Allah and this is the
role I'm supposed to be playing right
now. Right?
So, is that part of good character?
What about when
his brothers asked for his forgiveness
only after the boot was on their neck
and they absolutely had nothing left?
That's when they asked for forgiveness.
Did he say, "Oh, now you're asking for
forgiveness." Huh? What did he say?
You know what means?
I will not ever bring this up again.
Not only that, but in his dua, what did
Ysef say?
Didn't even mention him again. That's
it.
Said after Shan got between me and my
brothers, he brought up the issue. Never
never pointed a finger again. Is that
part of good character?
Yeah. Or is it just a smile? H on the
billboard. Vote for me. Right. Vote for
Mushul. Mushul for senator. Mushul for
Congress. We need to get We need to
drain the swamp. And we keep going
decade after decade to drain the swamp
and vote in for
devils
in the form of men. This has nothing to
do with good character.
Nor can you reduce a man to good
character because he makes you feel
nice. Character is something that you
can only know about a person after you
have tried them.
You can't say so and so has good
character and you haven't
as Omar would say someone would come to
testify to someone's character. He would
say
[Silence]
would say, "Did you ever deal with him?"
Money say no. Said, "Did you ever live
with him?" Say, "No." Say, "Then you
don't know him." That's it.
You can't know someone's character until
you rub up close and know them.
[Arabic recitation]